we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p take a
listen to this voicemail question about
a logical fallacy hey David
so I was in um my American government
class the other day and we were talking
about different logical fallacies and he
mentioned one called the appeal to
Authority fallacy and an example he
stated is in the climate change debate
where people say oh the science is
settled and he's saying that sort of a
logical fallacy I think his point was
you need to have statistics and evidence
ready to go to back up your argument but
I was just wondering what your thoughts
on that word and I was wondering if he
would do a logical fallacy video about
it maybe in the mini series yeah anyway
have a good day thank you we've already
actually dealt with this we've we've
dealt with appeal to Authority so appeal
to Authority is is a logical fallacy in
which someone points to the truth of a
conclusion from an argument on the basis
of the authority of the person making it
so for example it would be I don't know
well fire is hot because a fireman said
so the fireman saying it doesn't prove
that the fire is hot so in that sense
it's a logical fallacy but appeal to
authorities a little bit more
complicated let's see if we can think it
through we shouldn't believe that
climate change is real merely because
those who have the title climate
scientists say it's real they could all
be saying it and be wrong but it's not a
logical fallacy when you have a coherent
explanation as to why the consensus view
of a group of experts is actually
reliable so appeal to Authority and
appeal to scientific consensus are not
exactly the same thing climate change
skeptics and conspiracy theorists love
saying who cares what the experts say
it's an appeal to Authority and
authorities are sometimes wrong but
you've got to think about it in a
logical arguments format there's a
scientific consensus about climate
so climate change is true that is an
appeal to Authority if that's the full
extent of the argument but that's not
the argument right the reality is
there's a scientific consensus about
climate change among climate scientists
climate scientists have come to this
conclusion on the basis of decades of
studying their field and collecting data
the scientific community has both error
correcting mechanisms internally and is
known to be conservative in their
assessments and not going beyond the
data when they make assessments
therefore we can be reasonably certain
that the consensus of climate scientists
represents reality in accordance with
all of the data that we have it doesn't
mean scientists are always right but
saying climate change is real because
it's what climate scientists say is not
the same as saying climate science is
fake because that's what my pastor says
right those are two very very different
things and I'm glad you're thinking
about it we've got a great bonus show
for you today become a member
become a patron I'll speak to you then